hey this is just the best remember in
December when Donald Trump went on
Twitter and said quote Boeing is
building a brand-new 747 Air Force one
for future presidents but costs are out
of control
more than four billion dollars cancel
order at the time both Boeing and the
White House no less said that the claim
was not accurate Trump has now said that
he has saved the Air Force a billion
dollars the Air Force happens to have no
idea what Donald Trump is talking about
yet another one of these comp claims
that not only isn't even based on a
grain of truth it's completely untrue
last weekend at one of his campaign
rallies which by the way took place
months after the election a weird that
you're still doing campaign rallies
months after the election but Trump is
Trump said that he negotiated with
Boeing about two new Air Force one 747s
saying that he saved a whole bunch of
money here's Donald and just so you know
they were close to signing a 4.2 billion
dollar deal that has a new Air Force one
can you believe this I said no way I
said I refuse to fly in a 4.2 billion
dollar airplane I refuse so I got Boeing
in and it is actually Coupland a lot of
people don't know the Air Force one
project is actually two planes why they
need two planes we'll have to talk about
that but they have to play but we've got
that price down by over a billion
dollars and I probably haven't spoken to
be honest with you for more than an hour
on the project but I got the generals in
who are fantastic I got going in but I
don't Boeing it's not good enough we're
not going to do it the price is still -
huh
real men of the people by the way Trump
doesn't know why we have two Air Force
one planes there's always an identical
Air Force one within a 30-minute trip of
the one that's being used in case
something malfunctions as anyone who's
flown just a few times knows planes
sometimes malfunction but this
information about Trump saving all this
money is new to the Air Force it's what
you might call fake or made-up on
Wednesday when reporters asked
for spokesman Colonel Pat Ryder how did
Trump manage to save the Air Force a
billion bucks Ryder said quote to my
knowledge I have not been told that we
have that information the Air Force
doesn't know because Trump made it up
the same way that the media didn't cover
the Bowling Green massacre because
Kellyanne Conway made it up the same way
that the media didn't cover Shawn
Spicer's Atlanta jihadist attack because
he made that up the same way that the
media didn't cover what happened in
Sweden last night because Kampf made
that up he doesn't know why there are
two planes he doesn't also he also
doesn't seem to realize that this plane
wouldn't even go into service until 2025
so even if Trump were to win another
term he would still never fly on the
plane that is being discussed here Ryder
also said that the aircraft haven't
actually had a price finalized so it's
not even clear where this imaginary
negotiation would have taken place
reporters asked a bunch of times about
Donald Trump's claim but Ryder refused
to say anything else about it the White
House has not said anything about it
what do you think is going on here just
Trump just get carried away when he's in
rally mode and he starts making stuff up
yeah he's all about these small
victories on optics and even if this was
true that's exactly what that would be
kind of similar to when he bragged
nonstop about saving those 1,000 carrier
jobs which of course was an exaggeration
as we found out yeah because in the
grand scheme of things it doesn't mean
much I mean people know about what Air
Force One is they don't really know much
about these big defense contracts with
Boeing and Northrop Grumman and Lockheed
Martin and the rest of them I think
that's where you really got to make the
change and he wants to now raise defense
spending by 10% right yeah no it's so
funny how he said you know this spending
would be part of what he says he kind of
wants to spend more money on because
when you raise defense spending a lot of
it is guaranteeing contracts for
companies like the one he says he wanted
to take money away from even though he
wouldn't even fly on the plane and
didn't actually negotiate because
there's nothing to negotiate yet it's
just totally it's layers upon layers of
fabrication and officials not knowing
what Trump is talking about is nothing
new it's sort of the trend Mike Pence
rarely knows what Trump is talking about
Kellyanne Conway very rarely knows what
Trump is talking about in rational
voters
absolutely never know what Trump is
talking about so that I think is
something that is a continuing trend in
the Trump era people don't know what the
hell they guys talking about
it's like Mike Pence's performance in
the VP debate when they would make all
these accusations about what Trump has
said he just denied it yeah and with
sport or revealed that he didn't know
anything about it right when he was
completely pinned down and couldn't deny
that Trump has said had said X he was
actually I believe Y and we were
supposed to believe that there was some
kind of cohesive plan going forward well
there isn't than we're seeing that now
send me your thoughts about this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show